hey everybody sorry there's no nostalgia
critic this week but I'm actually on
vacation so by the time you see this
I'll be out of town and everything but I
didn't want to leave you with nothing
here so I decided to do a video on the
top 10 moments that made me cry and
believe it or not this is whether you
believe or not I don't know I'm not a
huge crier not that I have anything
against crying it's just I don't know
it's tough maybe because I love film so
much and I love show so much and
everything you can't get used to certain
cliches and so I mean like good cliches
even if they're done well you kind of
see them done over and over and so
you're kind of prepare for them so some
of these are almost like hit you off
your guard type of scene some of them
don't even always make a lot of sense
but they're scenes that got to me I you
know I don't always know why uh and it
was actually really hard to get down ten
of them I was kind of at like eight and
I had to really really think back so
some of them are like when I was a kid
you know I cried it at them when I was a
kid uh because some things didn't really
hit me as much like you know like
Bambi's mom or Simba's dad and stuff
like that like you know did for some
reason those didn't make me cry
uh but but these scenes did these make
me choked up even if I watch them today
a lot of times they get me to choke up
so I'll just give you a heads up there's
gonna be spoilers in all of these when I
mentioned something though I won't go
right into it you know I'll sort of say
what the movie or show is it doesn't
have to be a movie or show either it
could be a could be something on stage
one of these is a a on stage so yeah
I'll give you a heads up you know when I
say the title if you haven't seen it yet
you can turn down the volume and skip
forward I'm not gonna show any pictures
or anything like that so at least not of
the scene that I'm gonna be talking
about so blah blah okay we're just gonna
jump right into it then these are the
top ten moments in entertainment I guess
in general that actually make me cry
[Music]
number ten
my girl okay so this is one I saw as a
little kid I don't know if it would make
me cry today I haven't watched it in a
long time but I remember I left a pretty
big impact on me for those who don't
remember again I'm just assuming you're
skipping over if you've seen this movie
this is just the life of a girl pretty
much I think over the summer you know
sort of summer vacation and you know
just typical stuff she has a crush on a
teacher she like has a kid that she hang
out with played by Macaulay Culkin and
coke and dies in the movie he's allergic
to bees he goes looking for something
she lost I think it's like a mood ring
or something and there's like a hornet's
nest or something like that and he
stumbles across it a finds the ring but
all the bees and ordnance whatever they
are just sting him to death and she has
to live with the fact that you know he
died looking for something that she left
behind and this kid sells it I mean this
girl I remember just being so good and
giving such a genuine real performance
and you see it in the funeral home she
had her dad like I think already works
like at a funeral home you know and she
has to be surrounded by death already
and then like the only person that like
listened to her you know her best friend
is dead and she goes up and there's you
know Culkin in the casket in the suit
like just the dead makeup and everything
and it's one of those things where it's
like there's something about when you
see the body particularly in a movie it
just adds that extra like hit of realism
to it that's just like oh yeah okay
we're not skipping over this it's not
Bambi's mom where it's like who
off-screen you hear a bang or something
it's like there is death right in your
face
and she just beautifully reacts to it I
mean she just really takes it like a kid
what not just a kid but a kid like in
that situation and you know I seem to
remember as a kid like when when it
rained it poured and she goes out like
comes across the teeth or she has a
crush on like
is crying and everything and he you know
and she's like who's that woman it's
like well that's my fiancee and it's
just like oh my god like all these
incredible terrible things just being
thrown upon her so uh yeah I remember
that being very very effective and it
really hit me as a kid
and like I said I mean I I feel like now
it's still be effective I I don't know
if it had the same impact maybe it would
cuz again it's just the kid was so good
she just totally 100% sold it and was
very very believable and very sad see
number nine
Star Trek - yeah okay you know what
scene this is I be most of you have
probably seen this movie I'd be shocked
if you have if you're on my channel you
haven't seen Star Trek - but this was
another one I saw as a kid so as a kid I
didn't know that much about Star Trek
except the pointy ear guy Spock that's
Bach he's the logical eyebrow is always
Stern and you can't do that logically
you can't be ah Deana the other
characters I'm a dumb low kid who just
likes to see spaceships fly by and stuff
you know I'm not gonna get you know
super invested except for the weird
aliens and I'm err Spock was the weird
alien so I'm watching this movie you
know sir dozing in and out of it you
know again it's time for a kid to follow
bail on Star Trek but get to the scene
and yeah Spock sacrifices himself for
the crew and you see him slowly die in
front of curcuma character and I'm just
watching this like hey candidate that's
buck that's the only character I know
even though I've watched these other
actors and everything in front of you
it's like but Spock to a little kid is
the only one you know it's like the most
marketable character from that series
and to see him die at the end and he's
put in the casket and they're playing
you know Amazing Grace as it's going out
at me I'm just like oh I mean and it's
one of those boy death it's such a movie
death where like the character gets the
last words to the person but there's
like these little elements that make it
a hit more real like having his voice be
you know really crackly like that and he
never really talked that way and having
him even for a fall can be kind of
emotional but still logical - it was
it's like one of the most epic deaths
you know and I think for Star Trek to do
that as well even as a kid I'm like that
they don't do that on Star Trek that
that doesn't happen
now of course after that would kill off
many characters but yeah that was a big
hit to my childhood that was a big or a
real big hit there so yeah and the fact
that ended
he doesn't come back in that movie they
really thought he was gonna be gone gone
it was pretty potent it was a potent hit
number eight
Coco this is not the scene you think it
is again for anyone hasn't seen that
Mike Oh smiley yet but it's it's not the
scene that made everybody crying that's
not what did it for me even though it's
a very good scene and everything's
leading up to it but again you kind of
know it's coming it's gonna lead up to
something like that so you're kind of
prepared for it uh no but but the llama
got me is a little similar and it's
actually not at the ending it's at the
beginning beginning of the movie when
he's talking about so the great Graham I
think is a great grandma um and how like
she's so old her memories pretty gone
like half the time she doesn't even know
who Coco not gonna go whoo-hoo Miguel is
and you know and but she'll just sort of
sit there and smile and I yeah yeah and
he'll he just loves his great-grandma
and he'll come in and talk about what he
saw the wrestlers do today or you know
this new song anyway you know they
really want to play the guitar and
they'll talk about what happened in
school today and she again just probably
not even they're standing what he's
saying just sits there no they're
smiling and you can tell she's really
trying to pay attention and really
really trying to listen and she's just
feeding off his excitement even though
like both of them are probably not you
know through what they're saying or
listening are not getting through to
each other they're getting through to
each other in another way it's kind of
like each other's energy is like really
really feeding off each other and he
loves telling her these stories even
though he knows she probably can't
understand it and she loves hearing him
even though she's not really hearing
them you know I meet you where she hears
them but she's not really listening to
them or her minds - you're not good
enough to really comprehend what he's
saying but she can still get the emotion
of it and the passion of it I love that
that's really an eye it's maybe one of
the reasons is because when I was
younger I when I was about Miguel's age
my grandfather was living with us and I
loved going the he lived downstairs I
loved going down to him and just saying
like what I saw in Simpsons or what I
saw a Batman some stupid crap like that
but I thought it was really fun
it was really cool and I want to share
with him and he did the same thing he
didn't know what the hell Simpson's one
Heaviside he probably wouldn't even like
it you know but but he liked spending
time with me and he liked listening to
me and he liked seeing my excitement for
it and he didn't say that much you just
heard that ago oh okay okay bye he'd be
like smiling and like really trying to
pay attention even though he probably
didn't follow any of it
so yeah it's again weird stuff like that
gets to me sometimes it's not always the
big deaths or the remember those or
whatever it's sometimes it's just little
things like that beg for some reason can
hit me
number seven
voices of a distant star this is a short
film I saw I think it was in college and
this is pretty much interstellar before
there was interstellar it was playing
around with the idea that through
traveling through space you know be
using Lightspeed and stuff like that
time goes at different speeds so there's
this I forget how was she supposed to be
there's this boy in this girl I want to
say they're in college maybe I'm not
sure but they're each training to do
something against like some sort of
alien battle like the alien battles not
really that important just something in
war and she's a really good fighter and
he's I forget what he's good at it's
good at something but he stays on earth
and she goes in space to fight and they
have to do something where they travel
across galaxies pretty much and he's
gonna age more than she's gonna age and
they can only stay in contact just a
little bit in years and years go by and
it's still kind of this connection they
have even though they're not even seeing
each other I think like she sends a text
and it's something along the lines of
you know hello yeah something like
21-year old you from your 14 year old
best friend or something like that and
it's one of those things where it's like
it's such a drastic what the hell like
just age difference between them
suddenly and it's like the last thing he
ever gets from her and it's how they do
and don't somehow connect over the
galaxies and the stars and it's
interesting I'm not explaining it very
well but it's one of those things where
the difference between not only it's
literally the difference of space and
time separating them and and somebody
you still feel the emotion of it it's
it's very well dubbed I saw the English
dub of it and it's a very very good dub
it's gorgeously animated for it you know
did a for a short film they really focus
on the backgrounds here this I'm
blanking this guy's name but he's done
several animes that if you saw his style
you would recognize it it's very
background heavy um when the characters
are usually very very still it sort of
the backgrounds do the talking which is
not to say the characters drawings
aren't grades and stuff but it's very
background based and yeah it was it was
a very unique idea it was something and
they really saw and the way the emotions
work I can't explain I can't explain why
the emotions work or even how they work
in this because even sort of the main
characters can't it's a very it's not
even abstract because it's like it's
straight for what it's doing but somehow
their connection is abstract if that
makes sense
how they're still able to kind of
connect with each other and feel each
other even though they're not talking to
each other and they're literally
light-years away
it's a fascinating short I really
enjoyed it some things are a little
silly like the whole some of this very
traditional anime like these giant robot
bodies that they're walking around in
and these aliens they're fighting and
stuff but I don't know but then there's
little things like she's in this gem
robot body on this plant and it's
raining and she just says I want to feel
the rain like you know she hasn't felt
the rain in God knows how long she's
been in this robot body or on the ship
and the emotions all feel so genuine and
so real and yeah it it works it's very
good skal voices of a different distance
star and highly recommended
number six
little MatchGirl this is a short that
came out from Disney I think was
originally gonna be in Fantasia like a
know like another Fantasia movie they're
gonna do but you guys scrapped from
Fantasia mm they didn't do in our sequel
so they just made it I think it sound
like The Little Mermaid DVD or something
like that and and I saw it not knowing
the story I actually did not know how
the story went the Hans Christian
Andersen story and she's frickin broken
my heart but it's one of those where
again it's sort of very it's a downer
but it's also an up or those are the
moments that seem to hit me the most and
the way it's done at the end I think
most people kind of know the story and
again if you don't you should be
skipping this and not watching it but
it's pretty much a little kid in the
story they said in Russia for some
reason and she's just selling matches
and she hasn't got anyone Jesus orphan
whatever and you know she's just
freezing in the cold and she lights
these matches to imagine you know
something in them like she sees a hole
in the world in them and stuff and she
slowly to both keep warm and to let her
last moments on earth be pleasurable
imagines what's in the flame and she
sees like this you know wonderful world
of like you know that this her whole men
in different versions of the story home
can be different
sometimes it's religious theme sometimes
it's just a basic mother sometimes it's
a house or whatever and not knowing the
story going in when it gets to the end
and you see what I assume is supposed to
be either the mother the grandmother
comes in at the end and picks her up and
walks out and she walks past the girl
left there like she picks up the spirit
of the girl and then walks by her and
it's so quick you could almost miss it
but I didn't miss it the first time I
saw it and that was just like a like a
dagger just like boom in there but it
was also very hard well heartwarming and
just very very
very warm very loving and it it really
really worked and it's such a cold
I think the short really works cuz it's
such a great contrast of both is a lot
of cold too and you feel the cold you
feel are freezing out there but there's
a lot of warmth to it also you feel the
matches you feel what she imagines there
in this warm warm place and the warm
meal and so forth and that's really what
I imagine kind of this short is it's a
great mix of cold it's a great mix of
warmth and they come together
beautifully and I absolutely loved it
saw it as an adult not as a kid still
bawled my eyes out and I loved it
number five
avatar the last airbender and again if
you've watched my blogs you probably
know what moment this is it's a little
bit of a toss-up between these two
moments about which one like fully made
me cry by me the one that really really
got me it's I don't doubt it ever made
anyone else cry honestly I don't know
why this had this impact on me because
of play of cry moments in this show for
some reason this was the one that did it
it's when he's learning how to open his
chakras he he's learning how to pretty
much just drain himself of his desires
and his wants and and to be you know
something better you know but it also
connects him more to like what what kind
of love is and what energy is of
spirituality and stuff like that and the
the Guru wants him to eat this it's like
this banana onion juice and it's super
nasty and it's awful and he's learned to
love it you know the Guru and it Angela
it doesn't like it and once he gets to
the point where he's it's opening up a
chakra that somehow connects to you know
him and his connections to the people he
loves and how they love him and the love
that they share and the love he gives
back and stuff like that and he's there
and he's smiling and he's crying and he
says can I have some banana onion juice
please and I don't know why but I really
hit me if there's something about him
wanting this thing that he know tastes
bad and it didn't taste good to him but
it's like something has been opened up
where not only will he eat this because
he knows it's good for him it'll get
more of this great feeling and stuff
like that but he actually wants it like
he appreciates it he appreciates sort of
this awful thing that he resented now he
absolutely loves it and it's just going
through this you know very much this
meditative this meditative state of
opening up you know certain avenues and
his brain and his body that weren't open
before and now they are I don't know why
that that hit me that really hit me it's
so and then but one that came close
you're seeing I was talking about is
when Iroh is reunited with Zuko and he
gives them the big
and like Zuko is crying and he's
admitting how long he's been in stuff
and I wrote just doesn't even listen
after like two sentences he just grabs
him and he hugs them and it's just such
this hard fast like doesn't even look
him in the eye yet he just turns around
hugs him and it's beautifully animated
beautifully scored beautifully acted
just just so so well done but but that's
not the one that got me free it was the
banana onion you don't know why yeah
that's the one weird
number four
Wolfe's fraid this is an anime from the
people that did Cowboy Bebop one of my
favorite animes again very a little
MatchGirl what's kind of a mix of like
cold and warm this is very cold
there's definitely connections among the
characters and the characters are so
good but it's very cold just like it's
very standoffish it's very tough it's
it's it's very difficult and also just
the weather in general is very cold but
the scene I'm talking about because some
of you might even be like well there's
technically a lot of cry scenes in this
I get you got to give it away you got to
pretty much say what happens everyone
dies in this that's pretty much what
happens and you see like every death
that happens to every main character but
the one that got me that just like oh I
gotta I gotta lay down for a band look
at the floor after that was a top away
that man oh because this was like it's
it's the little kid I don't even know if
he's that little but but he sounds like
he's I'm he's gotta be I don't know like
12 maybe even younger like it like he's
like he hasn't fully hit puberty yet
it's a he's got this little voice and
everything and he's the runt and he
can't keep up and there's an episode we
have to can't prove himself and it's
everything with him is just it's like
he's clearly the heart of the story and
he just this other dog's owner because
they're wolves in this as well the air
dog's owner says look after this man
this hunter who is Brima tried to kill
him constantly trying to kill these
wolves and sure enough the hunters in
danger and he's about to be shot in
double-a jumps in front the cliche jumps
in front takes the bullet but it's such
a shock because you don't know yet
everyone's gonna die
so you just see like his body flying
towards the ground with blood spewing
out it's like no not all the way not
that character and just when you think
that's bad enough the hunters there
you know he's shot two and he's dying
and everything in tow Boyd just gets up
blood spilling from his bodies limping
towards for the hunter and he say I'm so
sorry I'm sorry I couldn't protect you I
just so wanted it like he's apologizing
for dying for him pretty much and to
make it worse they cut back to him
between being a dog and a human both are
just animated so well and so
gut-wrenching I mean the dog is limping
towards him and then you know the human
boy is just like crying limping towards
him and he just falls to the hunter you
know and and then you see like what-what
oh boy see he's seeing like this
afterlife he's reunited with his owner
and then the hunters realizing that like
he's saved him in the path of the oh man
okay oh god someone's gonna be going
it's okay it's it's such a good death
scene that when I figured out all the
other characters are gonna die
afterwards I was kind of like oh good
almost like all right that's just what
we're doing like something about the
idea of just him dying I just know it's
so curl and I it's one of those things
where I didn't I didn't know I didn't
want that character to die I mean to me
is just like against her the run to the
group he was the heart of the story he's
a character
he's a plot device but when you see that
happen I'm like oh no I had no idea
I cared that much for this kind of
character again maybe that's sort of the
the combination of both the positive and
the negative is that it brings out this
realization it's like oh like I really
did take that character for granted and
yet you can really connect that real
life to when somebody passes then you
feel like you took for granted I mean it
just creates this emotion you weren't
aware you were going to have
and that really did that for me I
thought that was very very well done
very well acted again I saw the English
dub and it's just so good I mean they
they just hits the bull's eye so well so
yeah that's uh and I'll miss me
number three
a Christmas carol with George C's got so
seen already has like what many people
would describe as like big cry moments
and stuff like that it's such a good
version that this is my personal
favorite even there even though I think
like the Alastair Sims one is is
probably better this one connects the
most with me I really George C Scott's
one of my favorite actors and they're
like I just can't think of a more
perfect Scrooge in terms of how I see
Scrooge Alastair since it's a totally
unique different thing and is is
brilliant I mean is so good that in
terms of like the traditional how do I
see screwed I see him as Georgie Scott
and the scene that sells it for me again
it's a weird combo but he goes this is
after he's reformed and he goes to his
nephew and his nephew and his nephew's
wife and we seen for the first time and
first of all he just sells it so well I
mean like the joy is so believable and
the regret is so believable you just see
the regret in his face the whole time
even though he's trying to be positive
he's trying to be happy you know with
his nephew and and all the emotions he
should have been confronting he's
confronting now and he's feeling them
for the first time like really feeling
this release you feel like every moment
he's there something is being released
off his shoulders and you know it's but
the moment that gets me is that he goes
to you know it goes into he's wife and
she says some along the lines of we are
so happy to have you here you've really
made our Christmas and he just has this
like he has never heard that before you
know like he played a part in making
somebody feel good and he just gives us
like he just goes have I like he just
and I even he doesn't say like that he
says it the best way George sees Scott
can say it and he just 100%
owns it and it feels so genuine and he
just hugs them both and says God forgive
me for the time of wasted you know and I
cut to the next scene and it's so quick
has so brief but I mean it's just like
that little you know
have I like to have I like really I mean
it's just he never heard that and he
never heard it and he never had that
impact and it's just this little moment
that you know kind of hit him and it's
not like a tradition although I'm gonna
cry over that because I've never heard
that it just served hits them and it's
one of those things we can know he'll
react to it properly later maybe but but
that stuff you wanna see off screen you
you know want to see they all you need
that little reaction that little have I
um and yeah this is one of those movies
I watch every year around Christmas and
I tear up every time every time I see
that reaction so good man I don't know
that guys have returned in a bad
performance even the friggin smoke
monster from All Star characters to the
rescue did it fine so yeah I absolutely
loved that movie absolutely loved that
scene you know the guy who directed that
directed the canneries babes and toy
there's no connection I just found that
out now I'm starting to wonder if that
was intentionally bad because you just
can't believe it's the same people but
nevertheless one of my favorite scenes
ever I absolutely love it and it makes
me cry every day
number two
fearless this is a movie a lot of people
don't know about is so adult so good so
psychological so emotional and it's
something so simple it's a dude who
survives a plane crash and how he deals
with it
that's it you think that we're like well
what else is there whatever I mean
there's a lot they do not shy away from
the impact that the plane crash had on
so many lives so many families so many
people but mostly it focuses on this guy
and then he finds another survivor and
it's it's how it just completely threw
his life out of whack he got set sort of
in this zone like he prepared himself he
was ready to die and he actually like
welcomed the calm before he died and he
was actually going around as the plane
was going down sort of comforting people
and after crash he was helping people
out because he kind of put himself in
this in the state of mind but then he's
still in the state of mind and he feels
like he has to still put himself in
danger and he has to feel like that
thriller cuz in his head he already died
you know but but he didn't die he's
alive and so it's him trying to snap out
of that he's not always likable most of
the time actually he's a jerk but you
somehow understand it you know what he's
going through and you want him to snap
out of it cuz you know he is good he's
just totally stuck in this odd state and
a lot of it is done visually there isn't
talking into two you know but I mean
it's done through very quiet moments
it's done of through a lot of moments of
reflection and it just had to cut the
flashbacks you don't have to know a ton
about his past or anything you just get
it from the way he's reacting off people
on the way he's reacting off of just
sitting alongside a car looking at the
sand on the ground like you just kind of
get it but the scene that gets me that's
the ending of this movie this is another
one of those like man that was kind of
life-changing again you have to go into
spoilers so if you haven't seen it here
we go
so um he prima tries to die he he's
allergic to strawberries and over time
he
slowly keeps kind of having strawberries
a little bit again kind of tempting fate
and it finally catches up with him and
his wife sees him dying and he's trying
to give him mouth-to-mouth and
everything and he says this is the
moment of my death
and so it's a it's going back and forth
between him dying on the ground and him
dying on the plane and what happened cuz
they slowly but surely show what
happened on the plane but not everything
you don't see everything until the end
it's not like a twist it's not like
uh-huh that's what happened no they
actually tell you exactly what happened
but you don't see it you don't
experience it until the end until he
goes through another death and it's him
both fighting for life and accepting
death at the same time and it's this
unbelievable middle ground where you
through very clever visuals brilliant
music and brilliant sound and brilliant
acting you feel like you're in between
life and death you just feel like you're
there and you kind of think he's gonna
he's gonna go he's gonna go into the
next world it's it's you know on the one
hand there's this threatening thing
going on where he's losing his breath
and everything but then on the other
hand there's this very warm welcoming
end of the plane you know where more and
more people disappear and he's kind of
leading them and then it's just him
going into this light at the end of the
plane which is what he did with the
other people and it's beautifully
brilliantly this is such a mad genius
film and then at the end just as he's
about to go on that light he stops for I
say here this breath of air come out of
him
as he's finally breathing again he just
cries I'm alive and he's smiling as
laughing and his wife is smiling and
laughing of it just going he's going I'm
alive I'm alive
stops stops right there you don't need a
second more credits roll really it's so
good just the emotion absolutely just
punches you in the face you know that's
not fair
it really really builds this whole movie
is it starts off kind of as a punch with
the airplane crash you just are
the planes already crashed and it keeps
building up to this point like up to the
emotional climax of it and it just
delivers so perfectly this is one of
those movies where I'm just like wow
I've never gone through something quite
like that it was so earned and it just
took such meticulous steps to get there
and emotionally it was perfect and the
dialogue was perfect the acting is
perfect it's just a solid brilliant
movie if you haven't seen that ruin it
for you you know but but who knows maybe
I'll get you to go see it if you hadn't
just absolutely stunning magnificent
film it really really really left an
impact and the number one moment that
made me cry is
[Music]
you're not gonna like it you're gonna be
so let down it's not a movie it's not a
show it's an opera it's ad to the first
op or I ever saw its vogner's Valkyrie
yeah I can hear so many people going oh
of course yeah I know you're all
probably let down by that I'm sorry this
is the first hopper I ever saw and the
second of the last third of it it's
pretty much one big goodbye
it's just one huge father saying goodbye
to its daughter forever and that's all
it is and this is a German opera so it's
like five or six hours man it's like
it's so long but this is one of those
operas where I just saw recently I saw
it again this year alive and I still
have the same impact it does it does
something I didn't know music could do
and I love music and I love music back
then I love it now who doesn't love
music but everything I thought music was
capable of and we were only sort of like
love this this song is doing this
variation of this thing I love and this
music is doing this variation of this I
love and so this just took me to a whole
new plane
like I didn't know this was possible I
didn't know music could do this and for
a lot of people it doesn't I'm just
giving you the heads up right now
there's a lot of people that can't stand
vogner it's way too slow it's way too
boring it's way almost kind of like a
drone and stuff like that I get that for
me what the music is doing is that it's
very slowly very cleverly wearing down
your defenses it's making it so that if
it through the emotional stuff that you
right away
it wouldn't work it has to very very
slowly kind of wear you down without you
being aware that it's wearing you down
and it's once it does that once your
defenses are kind of lowered it sneaks
its way in there
kinda tugs at your heartstrings and you
don't even know it's doing it it has
your heartstrings and then the story is
going on I actually even knew the story
going in I do exactly what's gonna
happen this is Vardhan saying goodbye to
Brunhilde is is a Valkyrie daughter for
going against his orders and I know
exactly what's gonna happen but it's
kind of like knowing somebody really
close to you is going to die just to get
you know it's gonna happen doesn't mean
it's not sad as hell and you're not
gonna feel these incredible emotions
about it if anything it kind of makes it
worse so I'm watching this and the music
and the words you know are just so
poignant and they're just so emotionally
fueled I mean it's just 100% driven by
the emotion of the moment and as been
building up to this emotion and when you
get people they're just so talented you
know that I've seen both these surgeons
at lyric opera I have seen several on
DVD as well and I just adore it and it's
it's still amazing and I did like I said
what sucks is that I know I mean okay
all this stuff not everybody's going to
get into it there's always gonna be
difference of opinion stuff I mean this
is one of those where people are so
divided on it and I get it and that
almost pisses me off because I'm like
guy you don't see the brilliance you
definitely that's not it I totally get
how someone won't necessarily get into
this music and get the emotion of and I
totally understand but but I really did
you need great patience for it and you
need to maybe need to go in like me like
you know sort of defenses up that's
usually how I go into you know I hate to
say it a lot of times how I will go into
a movie or a piece of art or something
because I don't do it to hate something
I do it because then when something
really does lower my defenses I
appreciate it
all the more and and it you let it kind
of change you in may respect if it's
done right so it's one of those things
where you I do it so I can have more of
an appreciation for it if that
make sense because then it helps you
separate people that do it good and
people that do it great and you respect
the people that do a great even more and
you want to analyze it and respect it
and talk about it and spread it you want
to spread it as much as possible so
that's why I do often go in you know not
always intentionally but just one of
those things where it's like I've seen
so many movies I have heard so many
stories where you know you do go in with
this mindset of okay I'll let see
something new I want to see something
that's gonna Wow me you know but I'm
willing to wait for it I'm willing to be
patient for it and that's what vogner
did for me that's what Valkyrie
especially did for me
so yeah it's one of those things where
it's like even if I I mean I have told
you the impact it has but it doesn't
matter you have to see it hear it and
it's either gonna have an impact on you
or it's not you know and it doesn't mean
one superior than the other doesn't mean
I'm more sensitive I more artistically
awoke or anything like that it just
meaning it either doesn't for you or it
doesn't and it really did it for me like
I said it just totally changed how I
looked at music and it kind of changed
how I looked at storytelling too and
it's still I hear this music
particularly that that last third and it
just gets me going
hey gets me going it's so good so yeah
there's a reason
millions of times you know at tons and
tons of opera houses you know I mean
it's just so phenomenal but but like I
said it's I'm sure that's not what you
were expecting but that that's what does
it for me man a lot of these I'm sure
they weren't what you weren't
necessarily expecting but a lot of the
big stuff like the parents dying in
films and shows and stuff like that or
the shock deaths I can usually sense
that I can usually feel incoming and I
have seen it a lot of times before but
that's why these moments that really
catch you off your guard are just all
the more potent and all the more
important because there are things that
catch you off-guard and they should they
absolutely should so go ahead and share
some of yours down below tell me what
holmen's get you tearing up and just
absolutely crying like a baby
and what moments caught you off-guard
like you didn't know you were gonna be
crying at them because there's a lot of
good ones and there's a lot of cool
stuff to share and a lot of great art
and great storytelling that makes us
feel these incredible emotions so share
some of those down below I love to look
over them and read them and I will see
you next week with an our nostalgic rig
it's gonna be a full review you know
it's not gonna be like an editorial or
anything like that it's gonna be a full
review so yeah I hope you guys enjoy it
and until then have a good cry
you